oui hein nous avons un problème hein nous devons
trouver quoi faire avec tous ces
employés tu sais que la facture trop longtemps
était comment tu es bon de te voir comment
c'est mon ami dan tu es un genou arrogant j'ai
appris beaucoup de oj fait  arrogant arrogant
de l'Inde bien sûr j'ai beaucoup entendu
parler de toi aussi ne touche pas que c'est
chris espinoza gamin dans la rue je
te parlais de I Smith oh ça va
être tellement cool super je suis tellement content que tu sois
excité par ce que nous faisons
ici, puis-je vous parler une seconde ouais
excusez-moi s'il vous plaît ne vous arrêtez pas et
allez juste à l'écart là-bas nous
ne pouvons pas nous permettre de payer trois personnes en ce
moment nous pouvons '  Je n'ai pas les moyens de nous payer à
moins que nous ne livrions Je ne m'inquiète pas pour
Chris c'est juste un gamin donc il était juste un
enfer tu n'es qu'un gamin